[Music]
friday edition pro football talk live
there are the odds to win the
professional football championship
otherwise known in some circles as the
super bowl the co-favorites kansas city
and baltimore at plus 650 and that means
bet 100 wins 650 bucks and then my gosh
what a climb from there from plus 650 to
plus 2100 are the new england patriots
and and these are the afc teams by the
way to win the super bowl championship
we'll be talking about the nfc teams uh
later
we're going to do
and and look
it it's kind of strange to actually talk
about football shireen all day yesterday
we didn't talk about football for the
first hour we didn't talk about football
but we're going to pivot now with the
season 13 days away
pro football talk live here to talk pro
football we've got 13 questions as we
sit 13 days away from the start of the
season we're going to start with the afc
that's why we're showing the afc team
odds
and let's begin right because we got a
lot of ground to cover here over the
course of the next hour and the top
question in my mind
as we talk about continuity of coaching
staff continuity of roster and all of
the distractions that make continuity
more important this year than ever
before
what is going to keep the kansas city
chiefs from becoming the first team to
repeat as super bowl champions since the
2003-2004 patriots
i think there's only two things that can
stop the chiefs and one is an injury to
patrick mahomes i think they could
survive any other injury but if it's a
long-term injury to patrick mahomes they
obviously recovered last year when he
sat out a couple games and had the ankle
and was a little bit gimpy
for those games they survived that but i
mean a long-term injury where he's out
multiple games i i think would hurt will
hurt their chances
to win the super bowl and and b i think
the only other thing that that stands in
their way is the baltimore ravens i
think they're clearly the second best
team in the nfl i know you're probably
going to say the 49ers but i think the
ravens are the second best team in the
nfl uh based on what they did last
season they had the best record in the
nfl they had home field advantage uh
throughout the postseason they didn't
take advantage of that obviously but but
they're they're solid they're locked and
so those are the only two things i see
standing in the way of chief's repeat
and if it wasn't for tom brady who's now
out of their conference it wasn't for
tom brady we'd probably be talking about
a three-peat for the chiefs because i
think they would have won two years ago
well and you think about what happened
to the ravens in the divisional round
losing to the titans if the ravens can
hold serve in that setting if they can
win that game the chiefs have to go to
baltimore the following week and if the
ravens
are able to win at home in the
postseason now we're still waiting for
the lamar jackson-led ravens to win any
playoff game and i think that's a
question that's going to hover over that
team until they win a playoff game with
lamar jackson at quarterback but you
know the ravens were the best team
in the nfl last year but i agree with
you the ravens if they can get it
together this year get home field
advantage again get the one seed again
the one seed means more than ever before
because only the teams with the one seed
get a bye if you're the chiefs this year
and the chiefs barely clung to the
number two seed last year they held it
together when mahomes was injured they
ended up with the two seed
what if you've got a play
in the wild card round what if you're in
the wild card round and the seventh seed
is a team from your division like the
chargers that's going to roll into town
and not be intimidated by you and maybe
knock you off on a week that otherwise
you'd be sitting at home in every other
year so yeah i think the ravens are the
practical impediment to the chiefs
within the afc
and you're right an injury to patrick
mahomes that knocks him out for more
than a few weeks is the kind of thing
that will completely derail the the
chief's effort to try to repeat because
look i look at their quarterback
position and it's a huge drop off and i
know you have faith in andy reid
and they did do well with matt moore for
crying out loud last year with mahomes
out they beat the vikings in in a game
that was a tough close game all the way
down to the end but there's a huge huge
difference between mahomes and his
backups i guess i don't care who the
backup is there's going to be a huge
difference between mahomes and his
backups and if that happens shireen you
know that then this talk of of uh the
chiefs winning two in a row is gonna go
out the window and i'm concerned that
there are multiple guys on the team who
are talking about winning six or seven
overall look they were down 24 points to
the texans they were down 10 points to
the titans twice in the first half of
the championship game they were down 10
points with seven minutes left in the
super bowl
this is a difficult rabbit to pull out
of your hat even for the chiefs and uh
there are a lot of things that can bring
them down but all those things said it
just feels like the table set for them
this year
yeah you can't understate what you said
at the beginning mike this is so
important teams that have the same coach
head coach the same coaching staff the
same coordinators the same offense the
same defense and most of the same
starting lineup it's so important this
year because they didn't have the off
season and you just you you can't
overstate that it's just it's crucial
and i think those are the teams you
point to that have the best chance to go
into this season and come out at the end
as super world champions and and they're
they're there i mean they have all of
that they they have everything in place
that they had last year when they won
the super bowl so they clearly are the
favorites and it's going to take another
team knocking them off or an injury to
patrick mahomes for them not to repeat
there's no question about that
and the ravens as you mentioned are in
the best position to do that question
number two
of 13 as we stand 13 days away from the
kickoff of the season how do the ravens
get over last year's playoff dud and
let's set the stage here
week 16
they clinch the one seed and i talked to
john harbaugh right after that game
and
at the time i kind of got the impression
that he was maybe inclined to keep his
starters on the field for week 17 like
bill belichick would do but it was that
calf injury to mark ingram that i think
at the end of the day
made him leery about putting lamar
jackson and other key players in harm's
way in a meaningless game so what
happens you've got three weeks
between
games that count
for lamar jackson and other key starters
and i i just can't help but think that's
one of the factors in causing the ravens
to fall to oh and two with lamar jackson
as the starting quarterback and uh look
now sure look you know when when you
start zero and zero and you have a
special season 14 and two and it all
falls apart
in that division around at home i think
it's tough to reset i think it's very
difficult to go back to zero and zero
and do it again that's going to be the
initial challenge setting the same kind
of tone
as last year you know everyone thinks
they're going to get to the playoffs and
maybe they'll be the one seat again it's
not going to be an easy climb
but but i think september october
i i think that that uh
it's gonna be a challenge
for this team to do what it did last
year because the end result for what it
did last year was a quick exit from the
division around and i don't care what
any player says i think it's hard to get
over that
yeah it's funny you should say that i
had a assistant head coach with the
raiders rich versace has said that
multiple times to me about how hard it
is to start over like you don't just go
14 and 2 and pick up where you left off
it doesn't happen when you get to that
14 and 2 you've got to take advantage of
it at that point because you don't know
what the next year brings you do start
over the next year so this is a new year
for this team they look loaded yes they
have a great coaching staff and that's
what i put put my faith in right there
is john harbaugh and that coaching staff
because i think they're very very good
and i think they can get this team back
to playing at that level i they're my
super bowl favorite and they're my super
bowl favorite because of john harbaugh
what he's done in winning championships
he knows how to get there and i think he
learned a lot last year in that playoff
loss if as anybody else i might not have
that much faith in them turning this
around but i think the ravens can turn
this around and be the team they were
last year and pick up where they left
off
let me give you a tangible example since
the chances of me being tormented today
by the drew pearson shove and catch are
fairly small until i said i've seen that
the the
the 1998 vikings randy moss's rookie
year 15 and 1 right
gary anderson misses the kick and it and
and uh hey all right let's fast forward
to 1999 they're going to take the nfl by
storm again they're going to have the
one seat and this year it's unfinished
business right week one they go to
atlanta unfinished business they beat
the falcons all right here we go 1-0 and
then they lost two in a row
and and it's wait a minute this team was
15-1 last year and now it's one and two
and the panic creeps in and they benched
randall cunningham and it actually
helped the team get the kick in the butt
that it needed to get back to the
playoffs and then got blown off the
field by the rams but yeah that season
is a stand-alone entity and it's gone
it's done and there's no coach like bill
belichick who can hit the reset button
no matter what happened to end the last
season and forget about it that is going
to be the challenge for john harbaugh
this year getting everyone in that
locker room to pretend that last year
didn't happen except for the parts of
last year that they can build on and
learn from but you can't walk around
thinking that you're going to be 14-2
again because there's a chance you're
going to be one and two and how you're
going to feel if you're one and two or
two and three how are you going to react
to that adversity when last year came so
easily and ended so difficultly and and
that's
that's the challenge for the ravens
especially because we're sitting here
talking about them being the primary
impediment to the chiefs we're assuming
they're going to be as good as they were
last year let's not be 100 sure that's
going to happen because the psychology
of it does become a factor
well and look at the division they play
in the three teams that are in their
division are much improved over last
year at least on paper with you know the
bengals have joe burrow who knows how
they're going to be with him they may be
better than everyone expects the
steelers have been roethlisberger back
and we we expected the browns to be good
last year and they weren't they
underachieved so are the browns going to
live up to that expectation this year
they've only added to what they had last
year when we were raving about them
we've kind of forgotten about them so
their division is going to be hard so
just winning the division is the first
step and what they should be
concentrating on not getting to 14 2
getting home field advantage all that
that will come if you take care of your
division but they got to win that
division first and that's not going to
be as easy as it was last year
it's amazing how the generally accepted
attitudes of the media will set those
expectations and set that bar and last
year the bar was way too high for the
browns and you could argue that this
year the bar is way too low for the
browns we don't know where the bar quite
is for the new england patriots that's
question number three out of 13 13 days
away from the start of the season did
the patriots
actually upgrade shireen at the
quarterback position
by adding cam newton following the
departure of tom brady
well i would start with is cam newton
healthy can he play a full season we
haven't seen that over the last two
seasons and that it's a huge question
because he missed two games and really
wasn't right two years ago with the
shoulder and then last year he only
played uh two games and and so we
haven't seen the cam newton that we've
we've grown to know and and respect and
was the league mvp in 2015 and did all
those great things i mean 2017 was
actually his last really good year so
it's been a while since we've seen that
cam newton so it's hard to say whether
they've upgraded or not we know tom
brady wasn't that great last season but
he did get him to a 12-4 record so it's
hard to say at this point just because
you don't know which cam we're going to
be getting
yeah you know i agree with you
completely by all indications he is
healthy now and if he is healthy i think
physically the skill set is an upgrade
over tom brady the area where he's going
to be at a disadvantage brady had 20
years of experience in that system in
that way in that entire
existence that meant being the patriot
quarterback and for cam newton it's
something that's happening on the fly he
just joined the team in late june it's
going to be a challenge to get to the
point mentally where tom brady was
because brady was there for so damn long
and i think it's a shared challenge for
newton to get up to speed and for the
team to get him up to speed and for the
team to be flexible in the construction
of an offense that gets the most out of
what cam newton does well and one point
to keep in mind here
the offense that josh mcdaniels created
for tim tebow in 2010 that he wasn't
able to use because mcdaniel's got fired
before they ever put tebow into play but
it was the offense that kind of
blossomed in 2011 after mcdaniels was
gone
and they got to the playoffs with tim
tebow in that offense it is conducive to
the quarterback running it is set up to
protect the quarterback and and cam
newton in an offense that is suited to
his skill set and that maybe keeps him
out of harm's way that could be the key
to cam newton being truly an upgrade
over the tom brady that we saw last year
because i think we can agree that tom
brady we saw last year wasn't as good as
the guy we saw in prior years so maybe
it will be an upgrade over 2019 tom
brady all right let's stay in the afc
east as we move to question number four
with tom brady gone from the patriots
are the buffalo bills ready to take over
the afc east shireen
boy they they've talked the talk haven't
they and now we'll see if they can walk
the walk i think the onus is on josh
allen
if he can play
better than he did last season he was
pretty good last year he got that team
to the playoffs but if he can play
better than he did last season take
another step
i think this team is the favorite in
that division again it goes back to the
quarterback and and how he can play i
think they've got all the other
parts in place adding digs at receivers
certainly is huge they now can throw
downfield if josh allen can get it there
and make some plays down the field but
on paper they look like the team to beat
in the afc east but a lot depends on how
josh allen plays this season
yeah you know and i agree with you and
sims and i both believe this is the year
josh allen reaches that next level that
there was a lot of confidence building
in the playoff loss to the texans and
you know there are times where he tries
to do too much and and and i'd rather
have a guy with the skill set that may
be guilty of trying to do too much than
the guy who doesn't have the skill set
and isn't willing to take risks i think
you can work with a guy
and and maybe get him to make better
decisions based upon experiences that
don't turn out the way that he would
like but that there are some reckless
tendencies there for josh allen they
need to iron those out he said this week
that he doesn't want to run as much he'd
rather get the ball in the hands of
playmakers and now that stefan diggs is
there i think that's a big difference
for that offense he hasn't had
that high end weapon at the nfl level
before and you could say at wyoming he
didn't have the high end weapons because
you know that was one of the reasons
given for him not completing all that
many passes
or at least not having the completion
percentage he should have had at wyoming
he didn't have the weapons now he's got
digs he's going to want to get the ball
to digs but i also still think they need
to let him run from time to time to keep
the defense honest and if they are
spending too much of their resources
trying to take away the downfield threat
and there's a whole
run be smart be careful slide get out of
bounds don't drop your shoulder don't
take a hit but he's got the speed and
he's got the skills and he showed them
off both his rookie year end last year
and there's no reason to completely
abandon that but if they can keep him
healthy
get him to make better decisions they've
got the defense the question is is the
offense ready to take it to the next
level and that vacuum potentially
potentially at the top of the afc east
look we're going to learn a lot about
the patriots this year
was it brady was it belichick and you
know brady's determined to make it clear
it was him belichick is determined to
make it clear it was him and if there's
any opening there i mean even without
the opening look at last year the bills
gave them all they could handle it came
down to week 15. there was a game
between the bills and the patriots where
there was an opportunity for the bills
to catch the patriots in the division
and and maybe the bills even if the
patriots are good can overcome new
england this year although i think if if
newton works out
boy it's hard to imagine the bill's
going toe-to-toe with the patriots if
cam newton ends up being the guy that he
was a few years ago
yeah you know josh allen has surprised
me with the way he's played his first
two seasons and and i do think he's only
going to get better uh this is a key
season i think for him because he can
get a contract extension
and if if he plays well and they make
the playoffs and do some things in the
plows frankly they should have beaten
houston in the playoffs last season and
they didn't get that done but if they
can do some things in the playoffs then
he's looking at a big contract and
they're looking at a bright future josh
allen's talked about we want to go back
to being the bills of the 1990s who are
competitive every year now i know they
want to win a super bowl which those
bills of the 1990s didn't do because
they couldn't get past the nfc east in
the super bowl
but they have that mentality that this
is going to be something that's long
term for them that they're going to be a
contender for a long time and they've
talked about that the entire offseason
now they've got to go out on the field
and back it up they've got to walk the
walk so to speak uh to get that done on
the field and prove they are that team
with all those kansas city chiefs
comebacks in the playoffs last year it
is easy to forget the bills were up 16-0
in the second half in houston and found
a way to blow that game and how they
recover from that you know these teams
that had
double-digit leads last year in the
postseason and saw them go away
how do they
recover from that you know how did the
texans recover from blowing a 24-0 lead
when they walk right back into the
lion's den to start the season a very
interesting question as the 2020 season
approaches here's number five on our
list of 13 questions 13 days away from
kickoff have the steelers become so
regarded as underrated going into this
season that they've potentially become
overrated shireen
i don't know that you can overrate the
steelers i mean the last time they
didn't have a winning record was 2003
that's a long time ago they are a
contender every single season they went
eight and eight last year notice i said
winning record in 2003 they did have a
couple eight and eights including last
year when they were eight and eight but
look at the quarterbacks they did that
eight and eight with ben roethlisberger
only played two games and he got knocked
out in that second game with that elbow
injury and they put two random
quarterbacks in there and still managed
to go eight and eight and were
contending up until the end for a
playoff spot so you know mike tomlin can
get this done he's shown that they have
a good defense in pittsburgh every
single year this team's again going to
contend for the division title we talked
a lot about baltimore being the favorite
in that division but i don't think you
can talk too much about pittsburgh just
because they managed to get this done
year after year after year
it's amazing you know it is funny it's
funny because
there was a stretch during the off
season where
you know we look at the steelers and say
boy people really aren't expecting much
out of them this year and those are the
years when they tend to be the most
dangerous and then people began to wake
up to that narrative and the pendulum
has moved without the playing of a
single game where people are like hey
watch the steelers and with
roethlisberger back the question becomes
who steps up in the backfield there's a
lot of buzz about benny snell second
year tailback he could maybe supplant
james connor there and then the chase
claypool talk the second
round draft pick the 11th receiver taken
this year
the headlines he's generating and i
think that the steelers are trying to
get their beat writers to maybe go a
little easy on the expectations that are
being heaped upon chase claypool but
they need a true number one receiver
because one thing we learned last year
juju smith schuster the team mvp in 2018
an mvp vote that went a long way toward
greasing the skids for antonio brown to
have a tantrum that took him out of town
for good
juju is not a number one receiver he's
an excellent number two he's not a field
stretching
double coverage all the time number one
receiver and if claypool can quickly
step into that role with the other
receivers they have to you know give
options to spread the ball around
this could be a very dangerous offense
my question with ben roethlisberger
shireen continues to be this
was the elbow injury last year was that
just one
aberration
or is it the sign
of the commencement of a guy who was
close to 40 who has
let's face it carried more weight over
the years than he should so there's more
pressure on the joints and the ligaments
and the tendons and he's taken a beating
over the years is it the start of a
breakdown physically of ben
roethlisberger so while we're talking
about the elbow the elbow the elbow the
elbow it could be by the end of
september we're talking about the knee
the hip the ankle the wherever
because maybe ben roethlisberger is at a
point where the spirit is willing but
the flesh is weak
and he talked about that yesterday he's
got to get over that first hit and
that's going to be important for him to
get to get back out there but you're
right at that age
things just start adding up the injuries
don't lessen uh they tend to get more as
you get up there in age and you know
this elbow injury wasn't just now i mean
it was serious and and there's only one
player i think who's ever come back in
the nfl one quarterback has ever come
back with it in the nfl and that's jake
deloam and he had a great season the
year after that and that's what ben
roethlisberger is hoping to do but it's
again it's another question of can he
stay healthy how's that elbow going to
be can he still get the ball down the
field i know he's rejuvenated i know
he's looked great at practice but there
are still those lingering injury
questions regarding ben roethlisberger
until he gets out there until he takes
that first hit until he gets through
half a season and then a full season
then i think we're going to say all
right well it was just an aberration at
that point but it's going to take an
entire season for us to to be assured
that ben roethlisberger can stay fully
healthy
and he's motivated he's talked about
winning championships s plural at least
two more he's only won two in his career
and i don't know how many seasons he has
left but i i admire the spirit i admire
the passion and we'll see what he can do
and what the steelers can do one more
before we take a break number six out of
13. is the afc south the deepest
division in football shireen
i would like the ascendant actually more
let's focus yeah let's focus on the afc
all right
i go the afc north still with what we
said with with joe burrow being added to
the bengals ben roethlisberger coming
back to the steelers the browns now i
think we're underestimating the browns
after overestimating them probably last
season and then the ravens were the best
team in the afc last season at 14 and
two at least in the regular season until
they got to the postseason i i love the
i love the afc south i think there's
some really good teams in there with the
titans the texans you got one team
that's not so good but i think the
quality top to bottom in the afc north
is better than the afc south
i'm going to actually agree with you
that the afc south isn't the deepest
division in the conference but i'm going
to pick a different division i'm going
to go afc west because of the chiefs
because of the charges yeah the broncos
i think are going to be much better this
year they've loaded up that offense and
i'm a big believer in quarterback drew
locke who didn't play much last year but
in what we saw i thought it was
spectacular and the raiders hey the
superlatives coming in this week for
derek carr the quarterback mike mayhawk
says he's taking over the team they got
the new stadium they got that five they
were seven and nine last year i think
team for team
the the west is the deepest and the
south look the south has
a a finalist in the titans
uh you know a consistent contender in
the texans and a colts team that a lot
of people are saying could make a run at
the super bowl this year it's just the
jaguars that drag down the average sorry
jaguars but it's true and they were a
team that was on the brink of the super
bowl just a few years ago so uh you know
the
and and again that seventh playoff spot
is going to keep teams alive
so much longer than any no one is
complaining about a seventh playoff team
i remember when they were talking about
being a possibility we were at the
scouting combine asking coaches about it
no one's against it anything that keeps
you alive that gives you that chance
that one last brass ring that's
available that one last golden ticket
that seat at the table they're all going
to take it and it's going to make the
season more interesting because i don't
you know i don't see more than a handful
of teams in the afc being mathematically
eliminated by the time we get to the
middle of december
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports